the 5-foot tall female like I'm really
short so I feel like if I can do this
anyone can do this my tents tents the
best female wort so school this sport
has changed my life and in every way I
mean opening your eyes to different
possibilities you know being able to
overcome your fear and it's really
inspiring and to me inspiration is one
of those powerful human emotions I'm
scared every day doing freerunning but
at the same time being able to overcome
that fear and to have the courage to
know within your heart that you can do
something and overcome that fear it's so
empowering so freeing our message is to
try to inspire people to to go outside
their realm to go outside their comfort
zone and try things that they never
thought that they could do and feel
success doing those things you know I
know we're not as strong and powerful as
the guys are but we can have just as
much fun and be just as creative and
just get as much true freedom out of the
sport as they can so it's really fun one
more download the aj+ mobile app and
join the conversation
available in your App Store now